Mary here with a gamespot news update
another sliver of evidence has appeared
for red dead redemption to during a Q&A
session with rockstar games although the
company didn't directly talk about a
sequel they did say stay tuned in 2015
for potential news rockstar said as
we've mentioned when asked in the past
about new games in other series such as
red dead redemption bully and LA Noire
we don't always rush to make sequels but
that does not mean that we won't get to
them eventually we have so many games we
want to make and the issue is always one
of bandwidth and timing we thank
longtime fans such as yourselves as
always for your amazing support and
please stay tuned in 2015 for
announcements of what's to come from
Rockstar Games previously rockstar
parent company take to CEO referred to
red dead redemption series as a
permanent one similar to James Bond and
Grand Theft Auto and red dead redemption
sequel wouldn't come as a huge surprise
with the game selling 13 million copies
it's basically only a matter of time it
is unknown what the new games rockstar
is working on to follow GTA 5 although
Rockstar San Diego the developer of the
original red dead redemption currently
has 35 open positions hmm suggesting
they could be working on something big
hmm well I know that I definitely be
down for last when some bandits in
first-person mode and if you are
interested in red dead redemption to be
sure to check out gamespot com / news
for all the latest updates
you